leave then won the season series against  Iran at the record of to another broad  James  explosive Toronto LeBron has five  assists for the Cavaliers  see how come get switched on no match  the crank LeBron James 39% shooting for  Cleveland Lowry follows Tipton stolen by  LeBron James  Cavaliers often running whips it  cross-court JR Smith winding down  DeRozan on the move  defensively DeRozan spawned by James  love tracks it down but he's on the  sidewalk packing  James with ten to shoot yes LeBron James  knocks it down 105 105  [Applause]  toward for bounces for James extra feed  Smith what's it's why it's a three JR  Smith Island target